en el aeropuerto de kandahar la multitud
se congrega alrededor de un hombre abdul
ghaní baradar es un momento de triunfo
para los talibanes porque es la primera
vez que uno de sus líderes regresa
públicamente al país desde que perdieron
el poder en 2001 dos días antes baradar
apareció en redes sociales para celebrar
la victoria del movimiento que cofundó
la cabra voraz boba oye que ahora
tenemos que intentar averiguar cómo
podemos servir a nuestra nación
[Música]
y garantizar la seguridad el confort y
la satisfacción para una vida pacífica
en el futuro final sacamos caudalismo
para dar nació en la provincia de
uruzgán en el centro del país en
1968 tras la invasión de los soviéticos
11 años después se hizo muyaidín y luchó
contra ellos bajo las órdenes de mohamed
omar con quien fundó el movimiento
talibán en kandahar en
1994 ostentó distintos cargos durante
los cinco años de mandato talibán hasta
cuando la invasión estadounidense lo
condenó a exiliarse a pakistán desde
allí comando la insurgencia talibán y se
convirtió en su líder de facto en 2010
fue arrestado cerca de karachi y pasó
ocho años en prisión hasta que
washington negoció su libertad con la
esperanza de alcanzar un acuerdo de
repartición del poder entre el gobierno
afgano y el grupo talibán para dar se
convirtió en el jefe político del grupo
y en 2020 firmó con eeuu la retirada de
las tropas de afganistán sin embargo los
diálogos de doha con el gobierno de
kabul quedaron en nada ahora está claro
que baradar sólo esperaba que su camino
de regreso al poder estuviera libre de
fuerzas extranjeras